welcome back we're now going to be in
the next section section four in our uh
fourth test and let's we're in problem
one on 594 problem one
x minus y is equal to eight
y is equal to three z
and z is equal to two
what is x
z is equal to two y is equal to three z
so y is equal to six
so
y is equal to six so x minus six is
equal to eight or x is equal to fourteen
e
right i just said z is equal to two i
don't know if i i sometimes forget what
i just said maybe i'm aging problem
number two
todd is older than marta but younger
than susan so let's say so let's say t
is their their their first letter is
their age so let's say todd is older
than marta so his age is greater than
marta
and it is all but he's also younger than
susan so his age is less than susan's
age
oh i think i did this problem
inadvertently if t m and s represent the
ages and years of todd martin and susan
respectively which of the following is
true
and exactly what i drew is choice a
and this comes straight from their
statements i literally was just writing
this because i thought they were going
to ask something harder but they're
saying todd is older than marta so t is
greater than m
and todd is younger than susan so t is
less than s so that's just choice a
problem number three
if the areas are of two regions are
equal and the sum of the areas of the
regions
is five what is the average of the areas
of the two regions so area one
equals area two we know that right
and we also know
that the sum of the areas is five so
area one is e plus area two is equal to
five
but then of course we know that area two
is the same thing as area 1. so we also
know that area 1 times 2 is equal to 5
or that each of their areas
is 2.5 and area 2 would also be 2.5 and
we we know that because they're equal to
each other and when you add them up it's
five so they're each going to be half of
that so they're each two and a half
and they want to know what is the
average
of the areas of the two regions well
they're the same number right so if you
average two of the same number the
average is going to be that number i
mean you could add them and divide by
two but you're going to get 2.5
and if you look at the choices where is
2.5 well 2.5
is the same thing as
2 and a half which is the same thing as
5 halves
so it's choice b
next problem
i'll switch colors problem number four
let s be the set of all integers that
can be written as
n squared plus 1
where n is a non-zero integer n is
greater than 0 and it is an integer it
is a non-zero integer which of the
following integers is an s
so n squared plus 1. so just let's get a
feel for what it is so n is greater than
0. so if we have so what is when n is
1 2 3 4 5 6. when n is 1
n squared plus 1 is 2.
so 2 squared plus 1 is 5. 3 squared plus
1 is 10. 4 squared plus 1 is 17. it's
always going to be 1 more than a perfect
square right 25 plus 1 is 26 32 37 right
so the choice is it has to be one more
than a perfect square so which of the
following integers is an s so choice a
is 16. 16 is a perfect square but it's
not one more than a perfect square right
similarly
choice b 28 28 if minus 1 is 27 that's
not a perfect square 35 minus 1 isn't a
perfect square 39 minus 1 is a perfect
square and if you look at choice e
50. 50 minus 1 is 49 which is of course
7 squared and actually we would have
gotten there if we just done one more
right 7 squared plus one 49 plus one is
equal to 50.
the
important thing to realize is is that
the integers in s are integers that are
one more than a perfect square so you
just have to look at the choices and say
which of these is one more than a
perfect square let's do problem number
five
so i have a circle here
that's my circle
and it has a triangle inside the circle
it looks something
i try to draw these as close to what
they drew in the book as possible
there's a point like that
it's like a point like that
and then there's a triangle it's like
that
and they write this is you know the
center of course is o
they're saying that this right here is x
they say that
this right here is y
and then the question reads in the
figure above point o is the center of
the circle if x is equal to 40 degrees
so x is equal to 40 degrees
what is the value of y
and you'd be like how do i figure this
out i know it you know angles of a
triangle add up to
180 and all that but they've only given
me one angle and i don't know this angle
or so you think you don't know this
angle
and whenever you see this
one of the things that should
immediately enter your mind when you see
this in the sat is the sides of this
triangle are the radius of the circle
right
it's a radius of the circle right
because every time it gets to the end
point and actually draw it like that
so if this is a radius we know that this
side is going to be equal to this side
because both of these sides are the
lengths of the radius of this circle and
they do this a lot of the sat they you
know if something is a radius of a
circle it never changes anywhere you
draw it right the radius is constant as
you go around a circle so this side is
equal to this side what do we know what
happens this is isosceles triangle and
the base angles are equivalent so this
is why we also know that this is y
because they're the base angles of you
know they're corresponding angles to
these two sides right they're the base
angles for this triangle now we can
solve it we could say x which is 40
degrees
plus y plus y right plus y plus y
is equal to 180
or we could say 40 plus 2y is equal to
180.
2y is equal to 140
y is equal to 70 degrees and that is
choice d
next problem
problem number six
a simple square is any integer greater
than one that has only three positive
integer factors
itself
its square root and one
which of the following is a simple
square
so it can only have three factors it
can't have anything else only so for
example a simple square like if we wrote
all of the perfect squares it was 1 4
9
9
16 25
25 36
if we write the factors this factor only
has one this factor is one two and one
this is one three and one i'm just
writing out all the factors i'm sorry
one three 3 9 1 2 and 4.
here would be 1 2
4
8
16. i'm just doing this as an example
you shouldn't do this on the sat but i
want to explain what they're saying
all of these numbers are perfect squares
right
but notice 16
has
itself
one
or itself one and its perfect square and
it has some extra factors while these
numbers only have its square root and
themselves and one as factors so these
are simple squares
right so if we look at the choices
choice a
a 121.
see 121 i know 1 is a factor i know
that's 11 squared i know
it's 121 and i think other than that
there's there's not any other factors
it's not divisible by three
see b
is a hundred well hundreds got a ton of
factors i mean it's got one ten and a
hundred
but it also has 2 and 25 it also has you
know
2 sorry 2 and 50 it has 4 and 25 has a
ton of factors other than its square
root so it's not choice b
choice c
81 same thing it could be 1
1 times 81 it could be 9 times 9
or it could be 27 times 3 and so forth
and so on so it's not choice c i think a
is our prime contender
choice d 64. once again tons of factors
outside of its square root you know it
has 1 64 and 8 but it also has 2 times
32
it has you know 4 times 16 and you could
go on 64 is a ton of factors and then
finally choice
e 33 e doesn't work because that's not
even a perfect square what squared
equals 33 i don't know
so that doesn't even work so it's
definitely choice a
next problem actually i only have 40
seconds left so i'll do it in the next
video see you soon